just because you swim with the fishes
doesn't mean you can drink like one The
Flash post credit scene settles several
questions we've always had spoilers
ahead
does it count as a superhero movie if it
doesn't have a post-credits scene it's
become such an industry standard that
the audience says have pretty much been
conditioned into sitting through the
credits in hopes of a glimpse of the
heroes being drawn into their next big
adventure or just doing everyday stuff
being the Cameo heavy movie that it is
it's no surprise that the flash opts to
use its Soul post-credits scene and one
last guest appearance the main movie
already features appearances by the DC
EU Batman and Wonder Woman as well as
decided lead on other specific glimpses
of Superman and an alternate universe
and cyborgified Victor Stone among many
others as such the presence of the last
unseen Justice League member in the
post-credits scene is welcome though not
entirely shocking the shows us the
aftermath of an epic Bender between
Barry Allen and Jason momoa's Arthur
Curry while it's clear that Aquaman is a
size Advantage Barry's super Speedy
metabolism protects him from getting
hammered or getting smashed like we say
over here this is something that has
been brought up in just about every
flash iteration out there
[Music]
I can't feel anything in the
post-credits scene Barry has clearly
been drinking the big man under the
table for quite some time as the
perfectly sober Barry recounts as
multiversal Adventures to stumbling
slurry Arthur the viewers get a glimpse
at the Antics Justice League members get
up to on their days off and also gain
some insight into where both Barry and
the DCU stand after the flash with this
scene-sealing turn as a villain of fast
X and his impending return to Atlantis
and Aquaman in the lost kingdom Jason
Momoa is riding the crest of the
cultural Zeitgeist harder than ever
funny as the scene is there's also a
heartwarming side to it the flash makes
it explicitly clear that Barry's very
lonely due to his lack of social skills
and the isolation that comes from his
superhero life and total dedication to
proving that his father is innocent in
fact he even explicitly considers Bruce
Wayne a detached figure at the best of
times his closest friend against this
background the Revelation that barrier
lease occasionally hangs out with Arthur
means that he does have friends after
all and together with his budding
relationship with Iris West it all
implies at the events of the movie have
made him confident enough to move on and
start building his personal life apart
from the fun of getting to witness to
Mighty Justice League members on a
friendly night out the post-credits
scene does some heavy lifting to further
establish one particular concept from
the movie The Flash features multiple
versions of Batman and the dialogue of
the post-credits scene makes a point of
driving home the fact that while they're
all Batman and Bruce Wayne they're also
all very different people
you're
you are yeah
for much of its run time the flash is
just as much a Batman movie as it is a
Speedster one from waving a power and
goodbye to both Ben afflecks and Michael
Keaton's versions of the character to
seemingly bringing back George Clooney's
Batman and Robin one the movie spends a
ton of time pondering different Batman
even before the post-credits scene
having Barry specifically bring up the
all versions of Batman the different
thing one last time seems custom
designed to reassure the viewer that
it's all right to have lots of Batman
running around which is probably a good
move given James Gunn's dcu's apparent
insistence to run with multiple ones
foreign